I can't I can't I can't judge well it's
a Freudian slip hello I'm Chris Olson
founder of flight Fuel Coffee and I have
gone through many different dating
scenarios some good and money Bob so
today we are going to be playing red
flags
your date only listens to sped up
Tick-Tock versions of songs I'm gonna
say yellow I don't think that's like a
horrible thing to do but also wow your
date asks you to follow them on
Instagram after the first date
a little why that's the question that
comes in my head and if we're following
each other naturally then that's great
too but what's the motive here if you're
asking beautiful is that all you want
your date says I love you before the
first date oh my God whoa whoa waving
that red flag that's ins that's well and
I'm not gonna call it insane but that's
a little that's too much you don't know
if you love me you don't know me your
date is checking out other guys at
dinner so what date is this though this
is your first date this is our first
date if it's our first date
it's gonna be like both a yellow and a
red we're not committed to each other
yet you know I can appreciate that there
are other hot people out there that
aren't me but I should be the hot one of
the night for you that night I don't
know it's not the reddest flag well
we're starting off on not the best foot
but it's it's yellow red that's an
orange flag and over explaining is then
my red flag so there we go your date
hums Meghan Trainor songs during your
day because it's me I would feel a
little strange about that again what's
your angle here if you genuinely love
them that's great green green green
green green green green green but why
why during our date are you humming uh
Meghan Trainor my sister's songs it's
kind of all three I would have to get a
read on you beforehand loving Meghan
Trainor is usually a green flag humming
them in front of me on a date to try to
get to tr for yellow your date texts
with green bubbles instead of blue
I can't I can't judge you well there's a
Freudian slip I I can't judge you that
not you can have whatever phone you want
the blue has introduced the unsend
feature I think it's maybe sometimes
makes you nervous because now I just
have to full front with everything I'm
gonna say but it's okay if that's if
you're a Samsung guy maybe you have a
razor a Motorola Razor anyone know that
one yeah right and that's cool maybe
you're vintage
your date calls you bro it really
depends on how I'm feeling that day I'm
not really like a bro like if you resp
if you could call me bro I'm not gonna
be like yes
bro I'm not gonna throw it back at you I
don't really know what to do with that
but if that's the way you talk then
that's okay I'm not mad at you and I I
right so bro that it's yellow your date
asks your birth time and location oh I
get it I get it I want to know your
chart as well so it's gonna be okay for
me your day only posts group photos on
social media that's fine I guess you
have a lot of friends or maybe you want
me to think you have a lot of friends no
that's okay that's okay I don't know
you're not selfish you're a you're a
guy's guy you love people you love
showing that you love people and that's
great I don't have very many group
photos because I'm alone
yeah
your day keeps pulling out their phone
during dinner oh
get off of that get off I work on my
phone for a living and if I can keep my
phone away for the entire day you can
too that's a pet peeve of mine if that
ever happens I won't go on my phone I'll
just sit and stare at the person and not
me and I'm not like but I'm just like
and that's it because come on
entertainment's right here if you see a
red flag just get out of there get out
of there date one it's easy to escape
from so these are my red flags so keep
in mind if you want to date me I am
single stale and probably will be for a
little longer just keep in mind yeah I'm
sweating